Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家分享一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。挑战中还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》（Aspiring Psychologist）播客。
Today we are going to be talking to Professor Ingram Wright. He is a clinical psychologist, a neurospecialist and an academic. He is also a bit of a philosopher and I found the conversation really inspiring and I hope that you will do too. At points his wi-fi was not too good and so it goes a little bit patchy in parts but I hope that you will persevere with it because it's only affected in very tiny patches. Yeah I hope you find it super useful and I will chat to you on the other side. Okay hi welcome along to my guest for today we are joined by Professor Ingram Wright. Hi thank you for joining us. Hi Marianne. Tell us a little bit about your role and how you got into it if that's okay. Yeah it's fine, so I'm
今天我们要采访的是英格拉姆·赖特（Ingram Wright）教授。他是一位临床心理学家、神经心理学专家和学者。他同时也是一位哲学家，我发现这次谈话非常鼓舞人心，希望你也会有同感。在某些地方他的Wi-Fi信号不太好，所以声音偶尔会断断续续，但我希望你能坚持听下去，因为这只影响了极小的一部分。是的，希望你觉得这期节目非常有价值，我们稍后再见。好的，你好，欢迎来到今天的节目，我们邀请到了英格拉姆·赖特教授。你好，感谢你的加入。你好，玛丽安。能简单介绍一下你的角色以及你是如何进入这个领域的吗？好的，没问题，我现在是
currently Head of Psychology Services in Bristol at University Hospitals Bristol and Western, so we're a large trust in Bristol. I'm a paediatric neuropsychologist. So in my NHS role clinically, I work with children with acquired brain injuries of various kinds. I've got links with the University of Bristol. So we run a neuropsychology training course for people who are qualified as clinical psychologists and then want to go on to do specialist training in neuropsychology. And also recently appointed by the BPS as chair of the division of neuropsychology and also recently appointed by the bps's chair of the division of neuropsychology so i represent neuropsychology nationally from a clinical point of view gosh so that's who i am well done you keeps me busy marianne i've got imposter
布里斯托大学医院和西部信托基金会（University Hospitals Bristol and Western）的心理服务主管，这是布里斯托的一个大型信托机构。我是一名儿科神经心理学家。在NHS的临床工作中，我主要负责患有各种获得性脑损伤的儿童。我和布里斯托大学有合作，我们为已经获得临床心理学家资格、并希望继续进行神经心理学专业培训的人员开设了神经心理学培训课程。此外，我最近还被英国心理学会（BPS）任命为神经心理学分会主席，所以我从临床角度在全国范围内代表神经心理学领域。天哪，那你真是太厉害了。做得好，这让我很忙，玛丽安，我现在都有冒充者
syndrome now well we've all got imposter syndrome haven't we i didn't say i was capable in all of those roles okay well i am confident that you are so we're very very lucky to have you with us but we first crossed paths on um twitter um i hope that's not ousting you that you were on twitter um uh and yeah you uh you know, your interest in neuro really spoke to me because I know that as an aspiring psychologist, it's one of the key kind of things to cover. How did you get into neuro? How did you get into specializing in that? So I think, well, I know I was interested in neuro before, I mean, during undergraduate, during the undergraduate phase of my development, I suppose I, I was interested in neuro, I was interested in developmental psychology. You know, there are things that just grab you, don't they?
综合征了。好吧，我们都有冒充者综合征，不是吗？我没说我在所有这些角色中都游刃有余。好吧，但我相信你一定可以，所以我们非常非常幸运能邀请到你。我们最初是在推特上认识的，希望我没有泄露你的隐私，说你在用推特。是的，你对神经心理学的兴趣深深吸引了我，因为我知道作为一名有抱负的心理学家，这是必须涵盖的关键领域之一。你是怎么进入神经心理学领域的？你是怎么开始专注于这个方向的？我想，我知道我在本科阶段就对神经科学感兴趣了，在我的发展阶段，我猜我对神经科学、发展心理学很感兴趣。你知道，有些东西就是会吸引你，对吧？
And it's sometimes hard to know what it is about that material that's grabbing you. And I'm not sure I've fully worked that out, but it was, I was inspired by the kind of neuro teaching that we, that we had at an undergraduate level. So, you know, part of that was just having some brilliant lecturers that really were able to convey their enthusiasm for the science. So I started off there and then I went on to do an assistant post with adults with learning disability in a sort of rather old and now what would be regarded as rather outdated hospital setting but there was lots of kind of neuro work in a learning disability setting and so I was kind of quite keen to
有时很难说清楚到底是什么吸引了你。我不确定我是否完全弄明白了，但我确实受到了本科阶段神经科学教学的启发。所以，部分原因仅仅是因为遇到了一些出色的讲师，他们真正能够传达出对科学的热情。我从那里开始，然后去了一家成人学习障碍医院担任助理职位，那是一家相当古老、现在看来可能已经过时的医院，但在学习障碍的环境中有很多神经科学相关的工作，所以我非常渴望
translate the neuro stuff that I'd done undergraduate into a clinical environment. I went on to do a PhD looking at development in children with down syndrome again with a slight neuro emphasis and I suppose I clung to that all the way through my clinical psychology training so every placement that I went on I would kind of carve out a little bit of a neuro niche so whether it was my older adults or my LD placement or my child placement I ended up being drawn to the neuro bits and I suppose and this this might be a kind of a bit of a regret really I probably neglected some other things I could have spent time doing I mean I relished the challenge of all the other aspects of of what
将我在本科阶段学到的神经科学知识应用到临床环境中。后来我攻读了博士学位，研究唐氏综合症儿童的发展，同样带有轻微的神经科学侧重点。我想，在整个临床心理学培训期间，我一直坚持这一点，所以无论我被分配到哪个实习岗位，我都会开辟出一小块神经科学的利基领域。无论是老年人、学习障碍还是儿童实习，我最终都被神经科学的部分所吸引。我想，这可能算是一种遗憾吧，我可能忽略了其他本可以花时间去做的事情。我的意思是，我确实很享受临床心理学所能提供的所有其他方面的挑战，
clinical psychology had to offer but I did find myself pulled towards the comfort of the neuro work that I felt I understood and was naturally um you know so capable of um so I mean that's kind of how that's kind of how I specialized I suppose very early but um and we might go on to talk about this I'm as someone who's kind of now in a leadership role with regard to neuro specialism I'm quite interested in people who are late converts to neuro you know people who don't start out thinking they want to take an interest in but are gradually coaxed into recognizing what it has to offer us as clinical psychologists whether they're psychologists or not so i suppose i don't necessarily want to broadcast a message that
但我发现自己还是被神经科学工作的舒适感所吸引，我觉得我理解它，并且天生就擅长它。所以，这就是我早期专业化的过程。不过，我们以后可能会谈到这一点，作为一个现在在神经科学专业领域担任领导角色的人，我对那些“半路出家”进入神经科学领域的人很感兴趣。你知道，那些一开始并没有想过要对这个领域感兴趣，但逐渐被引导去认识到它作为临床心理学家能为我们提供什么的人，无论他们是否是心理学家。所以，我想我不一定想传达一种信息，即
just like if you want to be an international tennis star you've got to pick up a tennis racket at four i don't think the same applies in neuro i don't think you have to enter into clinical psychology thinking you want to be a neuropsychologist if you want to be successful as a neuropsychologist i think you can convert late i think you can qualify as a clinical psychologist and find yourself in a neuro setting and maybe seek to qualify that's going beyond your question marianne isn't it but i i suppose i always like to kind of balance out what i'm saying by you know saying that there are other paths that are available you don't have to pick up a tennis
就像如果你想成为国际网球明星，你就必须在四岁时拿起网球拍一样。我不认为神经科学领域也是如此。我不认为你必须在进入临床心理学时就想成为一名神经心理学家。如果你想成为一名成功的神经心理学家，我认为你可以半路出家。我认为你可以先获得临床心理学家的资格，然后在神经科学环境中工作，也许再寻求专业认证。这超出了你的问题范围，对吧，玛丽安？但我认为我总是喜欢平衡我的观点，通过说还有其他可行的路径。你不必在四岁时就拿起网球
racket at four definitely maybe you do if you want to be an international tennis star but um but but if you want to be interested in neuropsychology you can leave it a little bit later and i think the incredible power of your story is that you stumbled across someone who was really passionate and really good at talking about what they did and got you on board and got you energized and excited about that which has helped shaped your career had you had a really rubbish neuro um uh lecturer at uni you know you might have come to it later but you wouldn't have got all that legwork in there. Yeah no I agree and I think that you know we talked just before we started about I've got three children and watch them go through various teachers at various stages and you can see and we've all probably had that experience
拍。当然，如果你想成为国际网球明星，也许确实需要。但如果你想对神经心理学感兴趣，你可以晚一点开始。我认为你的故事中蕴含着不可思议的力量，那就是你偶然遇到了一位真正充满热情、非常擅长讲述自己工作的人，他让你加入了这个领域，让你感到充满活力和兴奋，这塑造了你的职业生涯。如果你在大学里遇到了一位非常糟糕的神经科学讲师，你可能会晚一点才接触到它，但你就不会有那么扎实的基础了。是的，我同意。而且我认为，我们刚才开始前谈到我有三个孩子，看着他们经历不同阶段的老师，你可以看到，我们可能都有过这样的经历：
if you get a bad teacher in a particular thing you all of a sudden you think I don't like history um but you get a great history teacher and all of a sudden history is the best thing and you want to spend the rest of your life studying history so I think we're incredibly influenced aren't we by inspirational people that we that we stumble across who convey enthusiasm for their discipline and so I'm I'm as much a victim of that as anybody else but you know happily so yeah and I think that's partly why I do what I do I'm so passionate about what I do and I like talking about it and I want others to feel energized honestly I believe hand on heart that I forward slash we have the best job in the world like it's so varied and it's so lovely to be able to impact on people in such a positive way and with such variety as well and that's one of the things that sort of in the in the conversations that I've had
如果你在某个学科遇到了一位糟糕的老师，你突然就会觉得我不喜欢历史。但如果你遇到了一位伟大的历史老师，突然之间历史就成了最好的东西，你想花余生去研究历史。所以我认为我们确实深受偶然遇到的那些充满热情、能够传达学科魅力的人的影响。所以，我和其他人一样，也是这种影响的“受害者”，但很高兴如此。是的，我想这也是我做我现在所做事情的部分原因。我对自己所做的事情充满热情，我喜欢谈论它，我希望其他人也能感到充满活力。老实说，我真心相信我（或我们）拥有世界上最好的工作。它如此多样化，能够以如此积极的方式影响人们，而且种类繁多，这真是太棒了。这也是我在谈话中
you know what's really impressed me is I have a particular you know even within neuro or even within any specialty in clinical psychology or applied psychology, there are some specialties within, aren't there? So I'm a pediatric neuropsychologist. I'm interested in sort of quite acute diagnostic work. But what's been great about the podcast I've, you know, been involved in as a project is I've had conversations with people who are doing things which feels so very different to what I do and it's made me think even within a narrow specialty like neuro there's incredible breadth that I hadn't really recognized in terms of the approaches that people take and the conversations are delightful you know because you learn something about other people's passions
真正打动我的一点。即使在神经科学领域，或者临床心理学或应用心理学的任何专业内，也存在一些细分领域，对吧？我是一名儿科神经心理学家。我对相当急性的诊断工作感兴趣。但这个播客项目最棒的地方在于，我与那些做着与我完全不同工作的人进行了交谈，这让我意识到，即使在神经科学这样一个狭窄的专业内，也存在着我之前没有真正意识到的广度。在人们采取的方法方面，这些对话非常令人愉快，因为你可以了解到其他人的热情，
don't you that very distinct from your own but but are really comprehensible to us every day is a school day and you know we should be learning we should be stretching ourselves and before we started we were thinking about what we miss what we have missed out on due to the pandemic by not having you know conversations with new people that we meet um you know so it might be crossing paths um in interviews it might be crossing paths in um you know in um academic settings it might be crossing paths in um conferences and I love talking to random people I'm the sort of person that will strike up a conversation about cauliflowers you know in ASDA I am some people's worst nightmare but i found that i really missed that during the pandemic because people weren't wanting to talk to strangers and our social kind of norms of
那些与你自己的热情截然不同，但对我们来说又非常容易理解的东西。活到老学到老，我们应该不断学习，不断拓展自己。在开始之前，我们还在思考由于疫情，我们错过了什么，因为没有机会与我们遇到的新朋友交谈。这可能是在面试中擦肩而过，可能是在学术环境中擦肩而过，也可能是在会议中擦肩而过。我喜欢和陌生人交谈，我是那种会在阿斯达（ASDA）超市里和人聊起花椰菜的人。我知道，我是某些人的噩梦，但我发现疫情期间我真的很怀念这一点，因为人们不想和陌生人说话，而且我们那种微笑和眼神交流的社交规范，
smiling and eye contact were often a bit lost and a bit averted because of mask wearing and you know socially distancing so yeah i love a chat with a stranger and it's um we talked a bit about you know how podcasts how informal conversations like this whether they're about cauliflowers or whether they're about psychology you know bring something back in right so it's lovely to have these informal conversations they don't always feel i mean just like talking to a stranger in asda about cauliflowers doesn't always feel like it's lovely to have these informal conversations. They don't always feel, I mean, just like talking to a stranger in Asda about cauliflowers doesn't always feel like it's without risk. I don't think podcasting and informality is without risk, but I think if we strip it out and we stick to the safe stuff
因为戴口罩和保持社交距离，往往变得有些缺失和回避。所以，是的，我喜欢和陌生人聊天。我们谈到了播客，谈到了像这样的非正式对话，无论是关于花椰菜还是关于心理学，都能带回一些东西，对吧？所以进行这些非正式的对话真是太好了。它们并不总是感觉……我的意思是，就像在阿斯达和陌生人聊花椰菜一样，并不总是感觉……进行这些非正式的对话真是太好了。它们并不总是感觉，我的意思是，就像在阿斯达和陌生人聊花椰菜一样，并不总是感觉没有风险。我不认为播客和非正式交流是没有风险的，但我认为如果我们剥离掉这些，只坚持那些安全的、
and we stick to the conventional ways of communicating, we'll find ourselves heavily constrained. And that's still continuing, isn't it? In terms of the opportunities for us to get together face to face, they're still very limited and not everybody feels safe and understandably so. So I think we're going to have to find ways to have different kinds of conversations, take a few more risks individually and and and collectively um and benefit i suppose from the looseness of that of that kind of interaction yeah for sure um i'm yeah it was just yesterday that i was thinking oh maybe a in-person conference might be okay that feels like that might be
传统的交流方式，我们就会发现自己受到严重的束缚。这种情况仍在持续，不是吗？就我们面对面聚会的机会而言，它们仍然非常有限，并不是每个人都感到安全，这是可以理解的。所以我认为我们必须找到进行不同对话的方式，在个人和集体层面承担更多的风险，并从这种互动带来的松弛感中获益。是的，当然。就在昨天，我还在想，也许面对面会议可能没问题了，感觉这可能又
all right again now and we're also talking that there's not so much in the news about the pandemic currently so we're talking in early March 2022 and there's been a shift to other focuses in the news and so it can be easy to think things aren't still going on but of course we know that they are and people's lives are still being affected a great deal by COVID. You'd said just before we started recording that you've had COVID recently as well yeah and i i think um you know again like you say you learn things sometimes unexpectedly i i am i'm part of a long covid clinic it's a great clinic that's obviously been set up and it's a pediatric clinic um and it's been a real challenge because there's so much we don't know about covid there's so much we don't know about long. There's so much we don't know about long COVID.
可以了。我们还在谈论，目前新闻中关于疫情的报道没那么多了，所以我们是在2022年3月初进行谈话，新闻的焦点已经转移到了其他方面。因此，很容易认为事情已经过去了，但我们当然知道它们并没有过去，人们的生活仍然受到新冠疫情的巨大影响。你在录音前刚提到你最近也感染了新冠，对吧？是的，我认为，就像你说的，你有时会意外地学到东西。我是长新冠诊所的一员，这是一个很棒的诊所，显然是专门设立的，这是一个儿科诊所。这确实是一个挑战，因为关于新冠我们还有太多不知道的，关于长新冠我们还有太多不知道的。
And that seems surprising, doesn't it, given how much data we've had the opportunity to collect. But we've had to do the learning in such a short space of time that there are still massive gaps. And I suppose I brought some assumptions around what COVID was and what long COVID would look like, you know, based on, you know, historical assumptions and biases, I suppose that I did sort of acquired over a long period of time. But I found myself with a bit of brain fog, with a bit of fatigue, with a desire to get back to doing exercise very quickly after sort of beginning to recover from COVID and not all of those things worked for me right and I took on too much and I found myself lagging towards the end of the day and underperforming and doing all kinds of things that I thought gosh if I if I hadn't lived through this
这似乎令人惊讶，对吧？考虑到我们已经有机会收集了这么多数据。但我们必须在如此短的时间内完成学习，以至于仍然存在巨大的差距。我想我之前对新冠是什么以及长新冠会是什么样子带有一些假设，你知道，基于我长期以来积累的历史假设和偏见。但我发现自己出现了一些脑雾、疲劳，在开始从新冠中恢复后，非常渴望很快恢复运动，但并非所有这些事情都对我有效。我承担了太多，发现自己在一天结束时感到力不从心，表现不佳，做了各种各样的事情，我想，天哪，如果我没有亲身经历过这些，
I wouldn't really have an understanding of how that can affect a person do you see what I mean I mean I suppose we've all had coughs and colds, but COVID does feel a little bit different to that. In some ways for me, and it's about my personal experience, it did feel like a heavy cold, but there were other symptoms that I had that were entirely novel. And I thought this is something different, something we need to work hard to understand. And I think the same applies to long COVID. It's a complex, heterogeneous constellation to manage in terms of the breadth of clinical management. But I think we need to take seriously some of the findings,
我真的不会理解它会如何影响一个人。你明白我的意思吗？我的意思是，我想我们都得过咳嗽和感冒，但新冠确实感觉有点不同。在某些方面，对我个人而言，它确实感觉像是一场重感冒，但我还有其他完全新颖的症状。我想这是不同的东西，我们需要努力去理解。我认为长新冠也是如此。在临床管理的广度方面，这是一个复杂且异质的组合。但我认为我们需要认真对待一些发现，
for example, about brain changes following COVID. Those are not necessarily devastating changes, but for some people they will have a devastating effect, right? So the sort of group effects are concerning um but but what that hides is for some individuals these are major life-changing um events in terms of their cognition in terms of their ability and capacity to get on with their life as it was before um so certainly not to be trivialized um but on the other side like you say we're we're having to make decisions about do we run a face-to-face conference do we go to a face-to-face conference do we get on a bus do we get on a train do we take the whole day um we've been talking about this for a while haven't we and i never know whether to talk about covid or not to talk about covid but it feels like
例如，关于新冠后大脑变化的研究。这些变化不一定是毁灭性的，但对某些人来说，它们会产生毁灭性的影响，对吧？所以这种群体效应令人担忧，但它掩盖了对某些个体而言，这些是重大的、改变生活的事件，影响了他们的认知，影响了他们像以前一样继续生活的能力和容量。所以绝对不能轻视。但在另一方面，就像你说的，我们必须做出决定：我们是否要举办面对面会议？我们是否要去参加面对面会议？我们是否要坐公交车？我们是否要坐火车？我们是否要花上一整天？我们已经讨论这个问题有一段时间了，不是吗？我从来不知道该不该谈论新冠，但它感觉像是一个
such a big thing um and as you say there are there are other things going on in the world right now, the war in Ukraine, you know, and like you said, we're talking early March and we don't know where we're going to be in early April, do we, with regard to those kinds of things. So I think, but we still need to talk about work. We still need to do our work. We still need to kind of focus on the day job and one foot in front of the other, but sometimes it's quite difficult to do that, isn't it,
如此重大的事情。而且正如你所说，世界上现在还有其他事情在发生，比如乌克兰战争。正如你所说，我们是在3月初谈话，我们不知道到4月初我们会处于什么境地，对吧？关于这些事情。所以我认为，我们仍然需要谈论工作。我们仍然需要做我们的工作。我们仍然需要专注于日常工作，一步一个脚印，但有时这很难做到，不是吗？
when such monumental things are happening all around us? I don't know about you, but the pandemic, for the first time ever in my professional life, has been a great leveller, you know, for me being a human, for my clients being a human. And at the start of pretty much every session, you know, certainly for the last 18 months there's been a well how are you you know how is this and it's felt a bit more okay to say
当周围发生如此重大的事情时？我不知道你怎么样，但疫情在我职业生涯中第一次成为了一个伟大的“平衡器”。你知道，对于我作为一个人类，对于我的客户作为一个人类来说。在几乎每次会议开始时，当然在过去18个月里，都会有一个“你好吗？”，你知道，“这感觉怎么样？”，说出
yeah it's a bit tricky isn't it it's a bit unusual you know how are you managing that um and you know I've always been a human kind of therapist but it's very much been about I'm here for you and for me it is the first time that there's been more of that reciprocal care yeah um and it felt appropriate it's felt it's felt good and I think some of those things we have uh a slight discomfort with don't we so I've had this similar experience particularly running running appointments on, we use a platform called Attend Anywhere, but, you know, people will know various platforms are available that we can use to deliver clinical psychology into people's homes. But, you know, there are things that we can't avoid. I've got an exercise bike, as you know know sat behind me and people will ask questions about that I can try my blurred backgrounds but inevitably there's a degree of a sort of a lessening of the kind of
“是的，这有点棘手，不是吗？这有点不寻常。”你知道，你如何应对这种情况？而且，我一直是一个人性化的治疗师，但它更多的是关于“我在这里为你服务”。对我来说，这是第一次有了更多那种相互关怀的感觉。是的，这感觉很合适，感觉很好。而且我认为我们对其中一些事情感到有些不适，不是吗？所以我也有类似的经历，特别是在使用一个叫“Attend Anywhere”的平台进行预约时。但是，你知道，人们会知道我们可以使用各种平台将临床心理学服务送到人们家中。但是，有些事情是我们无法避免的。正如你所知，我身后放着一台健身车，人们会问关于它的问题。我可以尝试使用模糊背景，但不可避免地，会有一定程度的
boundaries would be able to establish in a in a conventional outpatient setting and it leads to a looseness of the of the interaction and in my role in pediatrics I don't find that particularly compromising indeed I've found it to be a an asset um and people do ask me how I'm doing how it's been for me um and I find that quite humbling really to kind of to experience that that that shift in terms of of where people's focus is in those kinds of interactions but I guess we need to be a bit careful that we're also trying to deliver care to people aren't we we're trying to ensure that we're focused on the needs of our clients rather than our own. And I think, you know, I found that quite a struggle. So I found that,
边界感减弱，而这些边界感我们本可以在传统的门诊环境中建立起来。这导致了互动的一种松弛感。在我的儿科角色中，我不觉得这特别有损专业性，事实上，我发现它是一种资产。人们确实会问我过得怎么样，对我来说情况如何。我发现这种转变非常令人谦卑，去体验人们在这些互动中关注点的转移。但我猜我们需要小心，我们也在努力为人们提供护理，不是吗？我们试图确保我们专注于客户的需求，而不是我们自己的需求。而且我认为，我发现这相当挣扎。所以我发现，
you know, when I'm having a tough day and I'm still trying to deliver my clinical services, it's not always easy. And thankfully, you know, for most of us, we've got the support of our colleagues, haven't we, to check in with with them but when those kinds of support networks have been challenged and rather thin on the ground it's um it's no doubt been challenging for us hasn't it to to continue to do what we do absolutely i think what we're what we're alluding to here is the issue of containment and actually that's a really incredibly important issue for us as qualified psychologists, but also as unqualified psychologists as well and aspiring psychologists. Have you got any top tips for helping feel more contained in careers generally, especially for when you're an aspiring psychologist? What do you find helpful when you're perhaps supervising assistants or junior members?
你知道，当我度过艰难的一天，却仍在努力提供临床服务时，这并不总是容易的。值得庆幸的是，对于我们大多数人来说，我们有同事的支持，不是吗？可以与他们沟通。但当这些支持网络受到挑战且相当薄弱时，毫无疑问，这对我们继续做我们所做的事情来说是具有挑战性的，不是吗？绝对是。我想我们在这里提到的是“容纳”（containment）的问题，实际上，这对我们作为合格的心理学家，以及作为不合格的心理学家和有抱负的心理学家来说，是一个非常重要的问题。你有什么关于在职业生涯中感到更被“容纳”的秘诀吗？特别是在你作为一名有抱负的心理学家时？当你监督助理或初级成员时，你觉得什么是有帮助的？
That's a really challenging question, Marianne. I suppose one of the things that I find is that I probably make all the mistakes that everybody makes around containment. I run a very busy service, whether it's psychological health services or neuropsychology. We run a course in Bristol where people with aspirations are trying to make progress with their research projects, with their learning. And the balance has sort of slightly been lost or at least is being challenged. And I'm not sure I have all the answers in terms of how we find that I mean I find myself scrolling through Twitter sort of news and following politics and stories of war and COVID and those kinds of other things and find myself drawn into cycles that I don't think are particularly
这是一个非常具有挑战性的问题，玛丽安。我想我发现的一件事是，我可能在“容纳”方面犯了每个人都会犯的所有错误。我经营着一项非常繁忙的服务，无论是心理健康服务还是神经心理学。我们在布里斯托开设了一门课程，那些有抱负的人正试图在他们的研究项目和学习上取得进展。这种平衡已经稍微失去了，或者至少受到了挑战。我不确定我是否找到了所有答案，关于我们如何找到……我的意思是，我发现自己滚动浏览推特新闻，关注政治、战争和新冠的故事以及其他类似的事情，发现自己陷入了我不认为特别
healthy in terms of those those conversations I'm also watching as I'm sure you are given the focus of your interests watching assistant psychologists applying for doctorates in clinical psychology. What I found quite helpful, and I mentioned to you, we ran a podcast with a group of assistant psychologists about working in neuro. What I thought was great is they had lots of ideas about solutions. So when they got together and talked about their experiences and where they're at in their career pathway, they had lots of advice for each other about how they could contextualize the challenges they're experiencing in a way that was really helpful. So one of the one of the best things I heard, actually, there were lots of great things that I heard last week, but one of the best things I heard is your career doesn't start when you successfully get onto a doctorate in clinical psychology. I mean, I've talked about how my interest in neuropsychology started when I was an undergraduate, maybe even started a bit before, but it's hard to
健康的循环中。在这些对话方面，我也在观察，我相信你也是，考虑到你的兴趣焦点，观察助理心理学家申请临床心理学博士学位。我发现非常有帮助的是，我之前提到过，我们与一群助理心理学家举办了一场关于在神经科学领域工作的播客。我认为很棒的是，他们对解决方案有很多想法。所以当他们聚在一起谈论他们的经历以及他们在职业道路上的处境时，他们为彼此提供了很多关于如何将他们正在经历的挑战情境化的建议，这非常有帮助。所以，我听到的最好的事情之一，实际上，我上周听到了很多很棒的事情，但我听到的最好的事情之一是：你的职业生涯并不是在你成功进入临床心理学博士课程时才开始的。我的意思是，我谈到了我对神经心理学的兴趣是如何在本科时开始的，甚至可能开始得更早，但很难
track back further. But everything that I did, particularly the things I did early on, have been incredible foundations for what I've done subsequently. And I'm so pleased that I didn't rush that process. I didn't feel that I rushed into clinical psychology. And I think a lot of the concern I suppose people have about how competitive it is, and it is of course competitive um tends to amplify a desire to to kind of rush the process to to apply early to to to do trial applications and things like that i'm not saying those things aren't valuable and they may well be the best route for some individuals but i also think there's a need for balance in terms of enjoying what you're doing right now and learning for learning's sake and really drinking in the experiences that you're having, whether it's an assistant, a volunteer, a health care assistant, you know, whoever, you know, supportive member of your family or social network. You know, I think those are all opportunities, aren't they, for us to learn things that will stand us in good stead going forward.
追溯得更远。但我所做的一切，特别是早期所做的事情，都为我后来所做的事情奠定了不可思议的基础。我很高兴我没有仓促完成那个过程。我觉得我没有仓促进入临床心理学。而且我认为人们对竞争有多激烈所产生的担忧，当然它确实很激烈，往往会放大一种仓促完成过程的渴望，去提前申请，去进行试探性申请等等。我并不是说这些事情没有价值，它们对某些人来说可能是最好的途径。但我同时也认为，在享受你现在所做的事情、为了学习而学习、真正沉浸在你所拥有的经历中方面，需要一种平衡。无论是作为助理、志愿者、医疗助理，还是你的家人或社交网络中支持你的成员。你知道，我认为这些都是机会，不是吗？让我们学习那些在未来能让我们受益匪浅的东西。
They really are. And I love the idea of actually it doesn't start on day one of training. It reminds me of the fact that I've been a home carer and a lot of the things I've learned about dignity, compassion and respect have come from that. That relationship that I've had with all of those clients and it was so humbling and so precious and special to me that I carry that in every every interaction I do as a clinical psychologist and there's so much value in these seemingly perhaps even non-psychology related professions that that can teach us so much yes and I find I I suppose, as I said earlier, we don't, we don't stop being challenged by those kinds of things when we're qualified or when we're on a training course. We, we still focus sometimes on end goals rather than processes. So, you know, in training, in specialist training in neuropsychology, you know, I find myself often talking about the viva and the portfolio that people have to produce. So the end product, if you see what I mean. And actually what we what we what we're now pushing to try and do is have many more conversations about how can you get the maximum value in terms of learning from from everyday experiences? Like you say, every day is a school day.
确实如此。我喜欢这种观点，实际上它并不是从培训的第一天开始的。这让我想起我曾经做过家庭护理员，我学到的关于尊严、同情和尊重的很多东西都来自那里。我与所有那些客户建立的关系，对我来说是如此谦卑、珍贵和特别，以至于我在作为临床心理学家进行的每一次互动中都带着这些。这些看似甚至与心理学无关的职业中蕴含着巨大的价值，可以教给我们很多东西。是的，我发现……我想，正如我之前所说，我们并没有因为我们获得了资格或正在参加培训课程，就不再受到这些事情的挑战。我们有时仍然专注于最终目标而不是过程。所以，在神经心理学的专业培训中，我发现自己经常谈论人们必须制作的论文和作品集。也就是最终产品，如果你明白我的意思。实际上，我们现在正在推动尝试做的是，进行更多关于如何从日常经历中获得最大学习价值的对话？就像你说的，活到老学到老。
Even if it's a Saturday, it's still a school day. Right. We can still learn stuff outside of formal education and we might not always pay attention to what we learn from supervision if we're just clocking the hours you know so in neuropsychology we've had this convention of counting the hours of supervision you have a bit like you might do if you need 100 hours of flying experience to fly a plane but actually what really matters is you can take off and land safely and you can cope with bad weather and you can do all of those things. But they won't all be part of the exam, right? So being a good pilot isn't necessarily about getting your pilot's license, although it's in part about that.
即使是周六，也是学习的一天。对。我们可以在正规教育之外学习东西。如果我们只是在记录时间，我们可能并不总是关注我们从监督中学到了什么。所以，在神经心理学中，我们有计算监督时间的惯例，有点像如果你需要100小时的飞行经验来驾驶飞机一样。但实际上，真正重要的是你能安全起飞和降落，你能应对恶劣天气，你能做到所有这些事情。但它们不会全部出现在考试中，对吧？所以，成为一名优秀的飞行员并不一定是为了获得飞行执照，尽管它在一定程度上是关于那个的。
It's also about what did you learn from the challenges you experienced in bad weather, tricky crosswinds and all of this kind of stuff and i just think we need to maybe refocus our attention a little bit in terms of that educational developmental process and these are subtle tweaks aren't they right but it's not only about uh encouraging students to think about or people who are in a learning environment to think about things in that way it's also about our responsibilities as leaders line managers supervisors and teachers to to to shift our focus of attention on what it is that we're learning what competencies we're trying to develop i love that idea of bad weather and that so applies in psychology as well doesn't it you know the bad weather might look like a non-attuned supervision relationship it might look like that time you said something awful or let a safeguarding concern you know not register as it should have done it can look like so many different things but it is
它也关乎你从在恶劣天气、棘手的侧风和所有这些事情中经历的挑战中学到了什么。我只是认为我们可能需要稍微重新调整我们的注意力，在教育发展过程方面。这些都是微妙的调整，不是吗？对，但这不仅是鼓励学生或在学习环境中思考的人以这种方式思考，也是我们作为领导者、直线经理、主管和教师的责任，去转移我们对我们正在学习什么、我们正在努力培养什么能力的关注。我喜欢那种“恶劣天气”的想法，这在心理学中也同样适用，不是吗？你知道，恶劣天气可能看起来像是一种不协调的监督关系，可能看起来像你说了什么糟糕的话，或者让一个保障问题没有像应该的那样被记录下来。它可以看起来像很多不同的事情，但它是
the learning we take from that so that it shapes our future decisions you know so that we don't let that safeguarding concern slip next time so that we are just a bit more hot on it. And we're more comfortable with talking about those things with clients and reflecting and reflecting in action, reflecting on action, all those other good things. And like you said, you know, we can learn about people's experience from hearing them talk about it. But, you know, like you said, with with the covid situation it doesn't you don't have to be hit by a bus to know it hurts but it sure does help help doesn't it it does help yeah i think it gives you insights into i mean i suppose i suppose what i would want to balance that out with a bit like when i was talking about how i got into neuro i'm also aware that not
我们从中汲取的经验，以便它塑造我们未来的决定。你知道，这样我们下次就不会让那个保障问题溜走，这样我们就会对它更加敏锐。而且我们更乐于与客户谈论这些事情，进行反思，在行动中反思，对行动进行反思，以及所有其他好的东西。就像你说的，我们可以通过听人们谈论来了解他们的经历。但是，就像你说的，关于新冠疫情的情况，你不必被公共汽车撞到才知道它很痛，但它确实有帮助，不是吗？它确实有帮助。是的，我认为它让你深入了解……我的意思是，我想我想用一点来平衡这一点，就像我谈到我是如何进入神经科学领域时一样。我也意识到不是
everybody's experience is like mine whether it's having COVID whether it's their journey into clinical psychology and beyond into into a subspecialty beyond that um and that's why having these conversations is great because you can kind of learn from other people about the journey that they've taken and I think we probably have too few conversations about those things. Another great thing I heard last week in supervision was about talking to assistants about what good supervision, supportive supervision looks like. And there's always something we can learn, isn't there, from hearing about other people's,
每个人的经历都像我一样，无论是感染新冠，还是他们进入临床心理学及以后进入亚专业的旅程。这就是为什么进行这些对话很棒，因为你可以从其他人那里了解他们所走过的旅程。我认为我们关于这些事情的对话可能太少了。我上周在监督中听到的另一件很棒的事情是关于与助理谈论什么是好的监督、支持性的监督。总有一些东西我们可以学习，不是吗？从听到别人的经历中，
how other people have benefited from supervising relationships that are different from the ones that we set up and deliver and a part of and and i i've really enjoyed kind of hearing about how i might be able to shape up the kind of supervisory relationships that i have into something that can maybe be more helpful um to assistants one of the things i wanted to say and it's sort of come up naturally for me as a as a thought is and particularly maybe in neuro that i've always experienced as someone who employs assistant psychologists for example a bit of attention between what the organization needs right so it needs someone to fulfill a role to do a job and
别人是如何从与我们建立和提供的不同的监督关系中受益的。我真的很喜欢听到我如何能够将我所拥有的监督关系塑造成可能对助理更有帮助的东西。我想说的一件事，它作为一个想法自然而然地出现在我脑海中，特别是在神经科学领域，我一直作为一个雇佣助理心理学家的雇主，体验到组织需求（对吧？它需要有人来履行职责，做好工作）与
do a good job and then there's thinking and i see those things as balanced against what the individual needs and one of the struggles is well how do you kind of achieve a balance which is comfortable both for the organization and the service and for that individual's learning and of course there are tensions that arise but one of the constant challenges is trying to resolve those tensions so that both the system gets what it needs and that individual in that in that role, gets what they need in terms of the support. Yeah. You probably spent quite a bit of time talking about that, Marianne,
个人需求之间存在某种张力。我将这些视为与个人需求相平衡。其中一个挣扎是，你如何实现一种对组织和服务以及个人学习都舒适的平衡？当然，会出现张力，但持续的挑战之一是试图解决这些张力，以便系统得到它所需要的，而那个角色中的个人也能在支持方面得到他们所需要的。是的。你可能花了不少时间谈论这个问题，玛丽安，
do you with, with people on your podcast and in your wider circle? Yeah, it's certainly, yeah, different, different functions for people's existence, isn't it? That can be hard to juggle and it's not you know i say to my kids it's not very nice but you're not the king of the world you know yeah the world doesn't revolve around you and sometimes you need to do things just because you've been asked to do them and um you know even if it's not something that's going to look great on your cv if it's within reasonable limits and it is on your job description,
你和你的播客听众以及更广泛的圈子里的人谈论过吗？是的，这当然是人们存在的不同功能，不是吗？这可能很难兼顾。而且，你知道，我告诉我的孩子们，这不太好，但你不是世界的国王，你知道。是的，世界并不围绕着你转。有时你需要做一些事情，仅仅是因为你被要求去做。而且，你知道，即使它不是那种在你的简历上看起来很棒的事情，如果它在合理的范围内，并且在你的职位描述中，
you know, mate, you may just need to do it. Harsh lessons in your household, Marianne. Because they're only eight and five. Yeah. One of the, I'm not trying to subvert your plan in terms of where you thought this conversation might go, but the other thing that's come up for me, comes up for me quite your plan in terms of where you thought this conversation might go. But the other thing that's come up for me, comes up for me quite a lot in terms of interviewing people with regard to that kind of tension. And who is this role for, right?
你知道，伙计，你可能只需要去做。在你家里学到的严厉教训，玛丽安。因为他们才八岁和五岁。是的。我并不是想颠覆你关于这次谈话可能走向的计划，但另一件出现在我脑海中的事情，在面试人们关于那种张力时经常出现。这个角色是为了什么，对吧？
What is this role for? Is that often when I ask people what interests them about the role, we sometimes hear an awful lot about how it will benefit the individual applicant if that makes sense and correspondingly little about how they can bring something which really benefits the service if that makes sense so it's a it requires a quite a fundamental mindset shift and I know that when I was applying for assistant jobs and PhDs and things like that it was all about what the role brought to me, very much so. And I really struggled to kind of think about what, what, what are the people on the other side of the table in this conventional interview want, want to hear from me? And it just
这个角色是为了什么？通常当我问人们什么让他们对这个角色感兴趣时，我们有时会听到很多关于它将如何使个人申请者受益的内容，如果这有意义的话；而相应地，关于他们能带来什么真正使服务受益的内容却很少，如果这有意义的话。所以这需要一种根本性的思维转变。我知道当我申请助理工作和博士学位之类的事情时，这完全是关于这个角色带给我什么，非常多。我真的很难去思考，坐在传统面试桌对面的人想从我这里听到什么？这只是
hadn't, it hadn't dawned upon me to even think about what they were expecting. And one of the great things about clinical psychology training, particularly I did it is that fundamentally I experienced a revolution in actually being able to think about people on the other side of the table simultaneously with also considering what I was thinking what I needed so there's a kind of metacognitive dawning really which was the entire clinical psychology training experience for me and I think it's probably made me... It's a reciprocal relationship, isn't it? It's a two-way street. Yeah.
还没想到去思考他们期待什么。临床心理学培训的一件伟大的事情，特别是我所经历的那样，是根本上我经历了一场革命，实际上能够同时思考桌子对面的人，同时也考虑我在想什么、我需要什么。所以这是一种元认知的觉醒，这对我来说是整个临床心理学培训的体验。我想它可能让我……这是一种互惠关系，不是吗？这是一条双向的街道。是的。
But if we're always thinking about, you know, if I'm having this conversation with you and I'm thinking about what I need, it's not going to be a very satisfactory conversation, is it? I think, you know, often when we're interviewed or we're challenged or when we're faced with a particular career aspiration and we see this process as being something we need to win at, you know what I mean? We become slightly narrowly focused, don't we, on a certain way of interacting that probably isn't optimal. Yeah, it's part of that listening to hear rather than listening to respond as well, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. And, you know, doing a a podcast a bit nerve-wracking isn't it we tend to narrowly focus
但如果我们总是想着，你知道，如果我正在和你进行这次谈话，而我满脑子想的都是我需要什么，那这谈话就不会很令人满意，对吧？我想，你知道，通常当我们接受面试、受到挑战，或者面临特定的职业抱负时，我们会把这个过程看作是必须赢下的比赛，你明白我的意思吗？我们变得有点目光短浅了，不是吗？专注于某种可能并非最佳的互动方式。是的，这也是学会倾听而不是为了回应而倾听的一部分，对吧？是的。而且，你知道，做播客有点让人紧张，不是吗？我们往往会变得目光短浅。
a little bit I should be asking you what you want to do if there's if there's anything you were hoping for from me today that you haven't heard me talk about you're doing a great job i'm doing a good job thank you yeah i mean i know a question that i get asked reasonably often from aspiring psychologists is well how can i build neuro experience i'm not getting you know i'm not getting shortlisted for neuro posts i can't get my hands on you know neuropsych tests that are worth thousands of pounds to you know to to sample on my partners or my family yeah I wouldn't recommend doing that in any case Marianne but is there anything people can do to bolster their skills and experience to you know without actually necessarily being employed
稍微有一点。我应该问问你想做什么，如果有什么你今天希望从我这里得到而我还没谈到的。你做得很好。我做得不错，谢谢。是的，我知道有抱负的心理学家经常问我一个问题：我该如何积累神经心理学经验？我没有获得神经心理学职位的入围资格，我无法接触到那些价值数千英镑的神经心理学测试，无法在我的伴侣或家人身上进行采样。是的，无论如何我都不建议这样做，玛丽安。但是，人们在不一定被雇用的情况下，能做些什么来增强他们的技能和经验呢？
within a neuro service I I think I think there's there's probably a, and it's not just a shift that we've experienced in Bristol, but there's probably a shift nationally that we're witnessing in terms of how, say, assistant psychologists get recruited. And my hope is that similar shifts are going on in clinical psychology, that we aren't asking people to demonstrate that they already know all the things that they're going to be expected to do um and i i i i'm equally enthusiastic as an as an employer as a as a clinical psychologist working in the nhs to to employ people who've got enthusiasm and interest in what it is that we do rather than you know a track record of doing this for the last two or three years because people who already know
在神经心理学服务部门内。我认为，这可能不仅仅是我们布里斯托尔经历的转变，而且我们可能正在见证全国范围内在招聘助理心理学家方面发生的转变。我希望临床心理学领域也在发生类似的转变，我们不再要求人们证明他们已经掌握了所有被期望去做的事情。作为一名雇主，作为一名在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作的临床心理学家，我同样热衷于雇用那些对我们所做的工作充满热情和兴趣的人，而不是那些过去两三年里有相关工作记录的人，因为那些已经知道
how to do it have less to benefit from the role and in thinking about what they need i think what we need to do is to give novel experiences to people who are thirsty for those experiences and those those individuals make the best assistant psychologists we've employed they're not necessarily people who are interested in neuro right but they're interested in learning something about a particular specialty in clinical psychology and it's great to witness that learning happening it's really inspiring for us as clinical psychologists in that service and it benefits those individuals far more than learning more of the same if that makes sense so again it's something that came up in the conversation i had last week with the assistants and there's
如何去做的人，从这个角色中获益较少。在思考他们需要什么时，我认为我们需要做的是为那些渴望这些经验的人提供新颖的体验，而这些人正是我们雇佣过的最优秀的助理心理学家。他们不一定是对神经心理学感兴趣的人，但他们有兴趣学习临床心理学中某个特定专业的东西，见证这种学习的发生真是太棒了。这对我们这些服务部门的临床心理学家来说非常鼓舞人心，而且这比学习更多相同的东西对那些个人更有益，如果这说得通的话。所以，这再次成为了我上周与助理们谈话时出现的话题，而且
incredible breadth in Euro. You don't have to be doing tests. You don't have to have tested your partner or your grandmother or whatever else you might think you need to do. What I think you need to do is have enthusiasm for the work that goes on, and the work is often far broader than you'd expect, right? So I'm sure you probably have this experience. If you're talking to someone and you ask them what they think you might be interested in it's often a quite a narrow representation of what they've managed to find out from a website but your interests are far
神经心理学的广度令人难以置信。你不必非得做测试。你不必非得测试你的伴侣或祖母，或者任何你认为你需要做的事情。我认为你需要做的是对正在进行的工作充满热情，而这项工作往往比你预期的要广泛得多，对吧？所以我相信你可能有过这样的经历。如果你和某人交谈，问他们认为自己可能对什么感兴趣，他们往往只能说出从网站上了解到的狭窄内容，但你的兴趣远比
broader than perhaps you know somebody might recognize from from what they can learn about you so i mean similarly when i'm talking to people um and they're only interested in the brain i think well you need to kind of be interested in the person as well as the person's brain um that's really important because the bulk of what we do is working with people um and it's about being a practitioner psychologist about being a health psychologist a forensic psychologist a clinical psychologist a counselor as much as it is being a neuropsychologist. And one of the great things about the conversations I've had with colleagues in neuropsychology is we feel the same. We don't spend our lives with our heads in test manuals
别人从他们能了解到的关于你的信息中识别出来的要广泛得多。所以，同样地，当我和人们交谈时，如果他们只对大脑感兴趣，我想，你不仅需要对大脑感兴趣，还需要对人感兴趣。这非常重要，因为我们所做的大部分工作都是与人打交道。作为一名执业心理学家，无论是健康心理学家、法医心理学家、临床心理学家还是咨询师，这与成为一名神经心理学家同样重要。我和神经心理学同事交谈时最棒的事情之一就是我们有同感。我们不会终生把头埋在测试手册里，
and moving blocks around on the tape. We do spend a bit of time doing that. It's quite good fun, right? And it's a great thing about neuropsychology that we've got that in our armory, but it's not what neuropsychology is. And we don't expect people to mould themselves on that kind of vision. It's such a broad church. I love the idea of actually, yeah, it's the person you want to recruit rather than necessarily the skills and this is perhaps some of the value of some of the clinical psychology tests for logical reasoning and you know how they think around different problems you want someone who's really good at problem solving and really enthusiastic and you know wants to do this and wants to do this well and wants to learn and as I was listening to you speak i was remembering trying to remember which order
或者在磁带上移动积木。我们确实花了一些时间做这些。这很有趣，对吧？神经心理学最棒的一点就是我们拥有这些工具，但这并不是神经心理学的全部。我们不希望人们把自己塑造成那种形象。这是一个非常广泛的领域。我喜欢这种想法，实际上，是的，你想招聘的是人，而不一定仅仅是技能。这也许就是某些临床心理学逻辑推理测试的价值所在，你知道，他们如何思考不同的问题。你想要一个非常擅长解决问题、充满热情、想要做这件事、想要把它做好并想要学习的人。当我听你说话时，我正在努力回忆
people had tapped blocks in and it was making me feel like oh no i can't do it i got it wrong which one did they touch first which one did they last touch do you do record stuff now these days has it moved on or is it all just memory and trying to know we still we we still do that it's that that test you described called the course he blocks it's a visual spatial working memory task and one of the challenges of doing that is that you have to have the working memory skills to be able to I think it's what you're saying to remember what the person has has done and and similarly we have a kind of sequential learning task we do with children where you knock tap and move your hands in various ways and then you watch whether the child can replicate that it's hard enough to
人们按什么顺序敲击了积木，这让我觉得，哦不，我做不到，我弄错了，他们先碰了哪一个，最后碰了哪一个？你现在记录这些东西吗？是已经进步了，还是全靠记忆？不，我们仍然这样做。你描述的那个测试叫科西积木测试（Corsi blocks），这是一个视觉空间工作记忆任务。做这个测试的挑战之一是，你必须具备工作记忆技能，我想这就是你所说的，要记住那个人做了什么。同样，我们有一种与儿童一起做的序列学习任务，你敲击、拍打并以各种方式移动你的手，然后观察孩子是否能复制它。这已经够难了，
do the dance let alone mark somebody else's dancing in response to yours so i think some of those things are quite esoteric and and good fun to learn but it's interesting you mentioned the reasoning task because i think we of course we're interested in people's problem solving but i do worry a little bit you must have seen have seen this stuff of how people feel about doing those reasoning tasks that are part of an application process. So I think we do need to think about what we ask people to do, how we ask people to perform, to demonstrate they've got the requisite foundations to be able to perform within the role. We did a great exercise recently around the,
更不用说还要给别人的舞蹈打分了。所以我认为其中一些东西相当深奥，学习起来很有趣，但你提到推理任务很有意思，因为我认为我们当然对人们的问题解决能力感兴趣，但我确实有点担心，你一定见过人们在申请过程中做那些推理任务时的感受。所以我认为我们确实需要思考我们要求人们做什么，我们如何要求人们表现，以证明他们具备在岗位上表现所需的必要基础。我们最近做了一个很棒的练习，关于
we've got some new trust values and we asked individuals who apply for our post to pick one of the values and talk about how it was important to them. And it was the best interview material that I'd ever come across, you know, in terms of everybody who contributed to that process excelled at doing this and they all excelled in different ways. And I would have had no hesitation employing any of those people. But it really was a very different interview process, if you like, to anyone that we'd undertaken before. So I would happily substitute that for a reasoning task because um because we were able to see the excellence of the candidates that we had in
我们有一些新的信托价值观，我们要求申请我们职位的人选择其中一个价值观，并谈谈它对他们为什么重要。这是我遇到过的最好的面试材料，你知道，就参与该过程的每个人而言，他们都表现出色，而且他们以不同的方式表现出色。我毫不犹豫地雇用了他们中的任何一个人。但这确实是一个与我们之前进行的任何面试都非常不同的面试过程。所以我很乐意用它来代替推理任务，因为我们能够看到我们面前候选人的卓越之处，
front of us and i think nothing has matched that that we've done in the past yeah and it allows them to be individuals as well doesn't it so there might have been six to ten plus values and they're able to pick the one that resonates with them and that's powerful having seen some of these reasoning questions i don't know if i'd have got through you know and I'm a really good clinical psychologist but certainly the ones I saw I was like say what now um so yeah your your style of interview would absolutely have suited me better I'm just conscious of the time and let me just think about your incredible podcast could you tell us a little bit about about what it's called and how it got started and um you know what it involves
而且我认为我们过去所做的任何事情都无法与之相比。是的，它也让他们能够成为个体，对吧？所以可能有六到十个以上的价值观，他们能够选择与他们产生共鸣的那一个，这很有力量。看过其中一些推理问题后，我不知道我是否能通过，你知道，我是一个非常优秀的临床心理学家，但肯定我看到的那些让我觉得，你说什么？所以，是的，你的面试风格绝对更适合我。我只是意识到时间问题，让我思考一下你那不可思议的播客，你能告诉我们它叫什么，它是怎么开始的，以及它涉及什么吗？
so i run a podcast called the neuro clinic um and the sort of schedule slightly sporadic but we've probably run about one of them a month uh it's it's something that started as we talked about with regard to covid and the restrictions that we had on the conversations we could have about cauliflowers and other things. And I thought, wouldn't it be great to have some of those conversations? And so in a sort of rather selfish way, it was just a nice way for me to have a conversation and hopefully not ruin it by clicking on record. So it's just been lovely to have conversations with other neuropsychologists um that i would otherwise bump into at conferences um but what's sort of taken things in a slightly different turn which is where you know we stumbled across each other is thinking about the people who are interested in this are also aspiring clinical psychologists neuropsychologists asking
所以我经营着一个叫《神经诊所》（The Neuro Clinic）的播客，时间表有点零星，但我们大概一个月做一期。这始于我们谈到的关于新冠疫情以及我们对谈论花椰菜和其他事情的限制。我想，进行一些那样的对话不是很好吗？所以，以一种相当自私的方式，这对我来说只是进行对话的一种好方法，希望不会因为点击录音而毁掉它。所以，能与其他神经心理学家进行对话真是太好了，否则我只会在会议上偶然遇到他们。但事情发生了一些微妙的转变，也就是我们偶然相遇的地方，即思考那些对这个感兴趣的人，他们也是有抱负的临床心理学家、神经心理学家，他们问
the kind of questions you're asking about what if I was interested in neuropsychology? What should I do? How might I think about the work of a neuropsychologist? Had some great conversations with people about being interested in neuro during their clinical training and where neuro or neuropsychological skills fit in terms of our broader formulation skills.
你正在问的那种问题，比如如果我对神经心理学感兴趣怎么办？我该怎么做？我该如何思考神经心理学家的工作？我和人们进行了一些很棒的对话，关于在临床培训期间对神经心理学感兴趣，以及神经心理学或神经心理学技能在我们的更广泛的构思技能方面如何契合。
We spent a lot of time talking about how there's a separateness around neuro and clinical if you like and what we need to do is to think about those being fundamentally things that we need to more effectively integrate and what I've learned I used to do some teaching and I'd say who's interested in neuro hands up and you get and you basically split the room so So a third of the people, half of the people would put their hands up and the other half people would fold their arms and tell you how they were quite fearful of neuro and they were not that interested in it. But it's a ludicrous question to ask that creates this kind of binary distinction between those who are interested and not interested and doesn't
我们花了很多时间讨论神经心理学和临床心理学之间存在的分离，如果可以这样说的话，我们需要做的是思考这些本质上是我们更有效地整合的东西。我学到的是，我过去做过一些教学，我会说谁对神经心理学感兴趣，请举手，你会得到，你基本上把房间分成了两半。所以三分之一的人，一半的人会举手，而另一半人会交叉双臂，告诉你他们对神经心理学有多么恐惧，他们对它不太感兴趣。但这是一个荒谬的问题，它在那些感兴趣和不感兴趣的人之间制造了这种二元对立，并没有
really address the subtlety um that's important to us about what we're interested in and i think where i started with this conversation was just thinking about you know i thought i was interested in neuro but i've discovered and i've realized that i'm interested in everything you know there's so much to learn isn't there so much to learn in clinical psychology and you're interested in humans. Interested in humans, interested in the humans outside of the brains and within their brains. And trying to maintain that balance is what's really important. And I think those conversations that I've been having have helped
真正解决对我们来说很重要的微妙之处，即我们对什么感兴趣。我想我开始这次谈话的地方只是思考，你知道，我以为我对神经心理学感兴趣，但我发现并意识到我对一切都感兴趣。你知道，有很多东西要学，不是吗？临床心理学有很多东西要学，而且你对人类感兴趣。对人类感兴趣，对大脑之外和大脑之内的人类感兴趣。并试图保持这种平衡是非常重要的。我认为我一直在进行的那些对话已经帮助
to sort of make that real, to sort of help me to understand how people achieve that balance in lots of different ways. Lovely. If people want to connect with you, Ingram, how can they do that? Where's the best place for them to get in contact with you?
把这种平衡变得真实，帮助我理解人们如何以许多不同的方式实现这种平衡。太好了。如果人们想和你联系，英格拉姆，他们该怎么做？他们联系你最好的方式是什么？
So I'm on Twitter a little bit too much. So I think I'm clinical neuro on Twitter and the podcast is called The Neuro Clinic. So I'd invite people to take a listen. And I'll be taking a listen to you, Marianne, in return. Good. Likewise. Thank you so much for your time today. You've been incredibly inspiring and compassionate and thoughtful. And I know people will find this really useful. And I do still feel a little bit in awe of you. So thank you. Marianne, thank you. Likewise. Thank you so much for listening i think you'll
我在推特上有点太活跃了。所以我想我在推特上是 clinical neuro，播客叫《神经诊所》。所以我邀请大家去听听。作为回报，我也会去听你的节目，玛丽安。好的，同样。非常感谢你今天的时间。你令人难以置信地鼓舞人心、富有同情心和思想。我知道人们会觉得这非常有用。我仍然对你感到有点敬畏。所以谢谢你。玛丽安，谢谢。同样。非常感谢你的收听，我想你会
definitely agree that our guest professor ingram wright was wonderfully knowledgeable i could certainly listen to him and his philosophical ways all day long so i hope you enjoyed the slightly more philosophical slant to today's episode. Don't forget, you can catch up on all previous episodes of the podcast. If you subscribe to the podcast, it should drop into your subscriber library at 6am every Monday, UK time. So that is a really great way to make sure you don't miss a single episode. And if you do enjoy it, I'd be really grateful if you could just leave me a rating. And if you've got a couple more moments, a review, which you can do on Apple Podcasts by finding the show, scrolling right to the bottom below the trailer, and you'll see the details there of how to leave a review. If you are following me on my socials, you will be able to see all of my content together, which includes a link to the podcast. It includes replays as a playlist
肯定同意我们的嘉宾英格拉姆·赖特教授知识渊博。我当然可以整天听他和他的哲学方式。所以我希望你喜欢今天这一集稍微偏向哲学的内容。别忘了，你可以收听播客的所有往期节目。如果你订阅了播客，它应该会在每周一英国时间早上6点出现在你的订阅库中。所以这是一个确保你不会错过任何一集的绝佳方式。如果你喜欢它，如果你能给我一个评分，我会非常感激。如果你还有几分钟时间，写个评论，你可以在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上找到这个节目，滚动到预告片下方的最底部，你会看到如何留下评论的详细信息。如果你在社交媒体上关注我，你将能够看到我所有的内容，包括播客的链接。它包括作为播放列表的重播
of the Compassionate Q&A series and also the Declan Sci Application Series videos too. And there is also details on there about how you can write for the next Aspiring Psychologist Collective book, which is very exciting. That is going to be coming out in autumn, in October. So there is still time to get involved if you'd like to be considered for writing your story for the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, do check that out. There's also a link on that Linktree site for details of the Aspiring Psychologist membership. So the extended phase of the membership is going to be opening again on Friday, the 29th of April at 8am, but only if you're on the waiting list. So there are already people there waiting. So if you like me, and you like my ways, and you think I think Marianne,
《同情心问答》（Compassionate Q&A）系列，还有《Declan Sci 申请系列》视频。上面还有关于你如何为下一本《有抱负的心理学家集体》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective）书籍撰稿的详细信息，这非常令人兴奋。那本书将在秋季，即十月份出版。所以如果你想被考虑为《有抱负的心理学家集体》写你的故事，还有时间参与，一定要去看看。那个 Linktree 网站上还有一个链接，提供《有抱负的心理学家会员资格》（Aspiring Psychologist membership）的详细信息。所以会员资格的扩展阶段将于4月29日星期五早上8点再次开放，但前提是你必须在等待名单上。所以已经有人在等待了。所以如果你像我一样，喜欢我的方式，并且你认为我想玛丽安，
and a little bit more closer access to Marianne would be really useful, then it will just be you and 29 other people. So it's really intimate really intimate exclusive access we do monthly group zoom training exercises there's also bonus content in there each month and each week there is lunch with marianne where we have a facebook live too so yeah there's lots of good things going on in there. For more information, check out the link tree for details of the Aspiring Psychologist membership. Also on the link tree is a brand new feature, which is support or donate. And if you do really like the free content that I provide, that I create for you, then you can help to cover the costs for the podcast. And for my time in editing it too yeah so that would be really welcome but there's no obligation but yeah until we meet again which
并且能更近距离地接触玛丽安会非常有用，那么就只有你和其他29个人了。所以这非常私密，非常私密的独家访问。我们每月进行小组 Zoom 培训练习，每个月还有额外内容，每周还有与玛丽安的午餐，我们也会在那里进行 Facebook 直播。所以，是的，那里有很多好的事情正在发生。欲了解更多信息，请查看 Linktree 以获取《有抱负的心理学家会员资格》的详细信息。Linktree 上还有一个全新的功能，即支持或捐赠。如果你确实非常喜欢我提供的、我为你创作的免费内容，那么你可以帮助支付播客的费用。还有我编辑它的时间，是的，所以这将非常受欢迎，但没有义务。但，是的，直到我们再次见面，
will perhaps be Monday at 6am for the next episode or might well be sooner if you follow me on socials or if you're already in the membership hope you have a wonderful week and I look forward to catching up with you very soon take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that you'll start to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many
可能是下周一早上6点播出的下一集，或者如果你关注我的社交媒体，或者如果你已经是会员，可能会更早。希望你有一个美好的一周，我期待很快与你联系。保重。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南，通过这个播客，你将开始走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。这让我感到惊讶，有多少
different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。